hey
did you just skip that ad the one that
plays before this video well
thanks a lot now we don't get the ad
money
it's like you ripped the eight tenths of
a cent right out of my child's mouth
welcome to the creator economy a vast
community of writers artists
personalities and pets who make money by
posting original content on one of a
dozen or so major social media platforms
it's one of the fastest growing
industries in the world with a recent
study predicting that 50 million people
worldwide will soon consider themselves
creators but is it really a job or more
of a small business or
just a crap shoot
[Music]
there are several ways to make money as
a content creator and the oldest is
advertising most of the major platforms
offer some kind of ad revenue sharing
with their creators the amounts vary
depending on popularity and platform
tick tock will pay as little as 30 or 40
bucks for a million views while the same
number on youtube can get you thousands
this is still generally not enough to
pay the bills so many creators look for
brand sponsorships when advertisers pay
them directly for promoting products
within the content you can also sell
your own merch or even start your own
product line like fashion cosmetics or
exercise equipment of course all these
options only exist for creators that
already have a large dedicated fan base
a recent trend offers creators more
direct ways to monetize sites like
patreon sub stack and only fans allow
artists writers and
personalities to sell access to their
work directly to their audience twitch
lets you financially support your
favorite streamers and even twitter now
has a tipping option
wow with all these money-making avenues
it seems like being a creator might not
be such a terrible financial decision
after all well we won't know until we
run the numbers
two years ago kyle started a youtube
channel to showcase his ukulele skills
after a lot of dedication and hard work
he now manages to put out a quality
video every week and gets a respectable
80 000 views on average that puts him
squarely in the top five percent of
youtubers on earth nice work kyle for
his success youtube pays him a weekly ad
share revenue of
two hundred dollars
okay not great but wait forgot to take
out youtube's cut ouch uh that's okay
because kyle is finally getting some
branded sponsorships about one a month
he's also selling a bit of merch and has
a dozen patreon supporters for a grand
monthly total of 2
343
not bad for a side hustle
wait what's that kyle this isn't your
side hustle
you
you quit your job for this
most serious creators will tell you this
is no part-time gig between the writing
shooting editing replying to fans making
graphics looking for sponsors studying
analytics designing merch and running a
patreon
managing a successful channel can
overwhelm a team of people let alone one
when you factor in equipment costs and
the two years he spent building his
audience kyle is working far below
minimum wage on this dream job
meanwhile his job security and benefits
are practically nil he's busting his
hump to create content for a giant tech
company that gives him no health
insurance no retirement and at any time
could make changes to their algorithm or
revenue plan that totally disrupts his
business strategy kyle's predicament is
sadly common for successful content
creators sure the handful of top
channels can pull in millions but
earnings drop steeply as you go down the
ladder one study estimated that you can
be in the top 3
of youtubers and make less than
one-third the median u.s income in order
to make the u.s median income on twitch
you have to be in the top
.015 percent of active streamers for the
median income
and those who are already wealthy and
famous enjoy a massive head start having
a glamorous life as a backdrop gives you
a big edge in the battle for eyeballs
and who else would have the time to
spend years building an audience for no
pay if you look at the highest earning
instagram accounts you'll notice that
they all got famous via traditional
media i wouldn't exactly call them
successes of the creator economy even
for those who managed to eke out a
living burnout is a constant hazard
unlike a musician or filmmaker that can
release a new album or film every few
years creators must be constantly
posting new content just to not fall
behind audiences and algorithms punish
time off severely and with all the
harassment toxicity and judgment on
social media the spotlight can take an
emotional toll on even the most
successful online celebrities and yet
millions of people still aspire to be a
creator
twenty-nine percent of gen zers said
they wanted to be
a youtube star
if it's your dream probably nothing
we've said has changed your mind why
because there's also a non-financial
benefit that creators are pursuing
call it fame attention or clout humans
have always had a keen awareness of
where they rank in the social hierarchy
and social media has turbo charged that
need as we live more and more of our
lives online our perception of
self-worth has become linked to likes
and follows a handful of tech companies
are now the arbiters of how status is
allocated and the more we battle for it
the more money they make
there's a lot of talk about how fast the
creator economy is growing but if you
look at where the investment dollars are
going it's not to the creators
themselves but to companies that sell
tools and services to creators pietra
helps influencers launch product lines
pair pop monetizes your social media
interactions and nunu lets you charge
your fans to vote on what you have for
breakfast in this way the creator
economy is less like an artist's
marketplace and more like a gold rush
a very small few will strike it rich the
majority crawl home empty-handed but the
smart money is on the people who sell
the picks and shovels
there are a lot of companies out there
that want to make being a creator seem
easier and more profitable than it
really is because they make money off
the dreamers
julia and i have done pretty well as
creators but we're part of a big team
that makes this show a success and
almost all of us have other jobs and we
have the financial and marketing support
of a large organization behind us i
promise we're not here to crush your
dreams being a successful artist or
entertainer requires talent hard work
and a realistic assessment of the
financial landscape so if you are one of
the 50 million creators across the globe
by all means follow your dreams just
make sure they're your dreams and not
ones that have been sold to you by
someone else
and that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description to become a two cents
patron
[Music]
if you've dipped your toe in the crater
economy let us know how it's going in
the comments below